foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is James page in Madrid at the
ftth council Europe meeting and I'm
really pleased to say I've been joined
by Camilla klot who is the acting
director connectivity at DG connect
Camilla thank you for coming and talk to
us
um European commission has its path to a
digital decade road map perhaps you can
tell us a bit more about it and some of
the initiatives that sit underneath it
thank you very much and thank you for
inviting me yes indeed we adopted very
ambitious digital decade communication
and then policy program which basically
has a several targets concentrating on
several aspects which are important for
digital but very much also focusing on
connectivity among these targets and for
connectivity we established a Target
that by 2030 all households all all
businesses in the EU should be covered
by fiber fiber to the home Fireball the
premises
and this target is extremely important
for us we also see the the impact of
connectivity on everybody's life so we
are really aiming to monitor what is the
situation in each of the member states
what is the situation in the EU and try
to help to achieve the surrogates the
current numbers but we are also looking
into new numbers which will publish also
soon but the current available numbers
are 56 percent in the EU are covered by
fiber to the home according to what we
see if that's the numbers from last year
July 2022 we are still cracking the
numbers for the new report which will be
issued in mid-june but the number that
the figures increased a bit but not
considerably also what is supposed to
mention there are significant
differences between the member states
between the countries not to mention
also differences locally between rural
and urban areas one of the examples
which is quite striking is for example
in Romania the the car foreignty is very
high I think it's around 80 percent why
in for example Romania is 20 and this is
what I am talking average across the
country not making a difference between
rural and urban areas which of course
are different we always see that urban
areas are more covered and the
households are more connected into
businesses than in rural area so still a
lot of things to do we are also looking
into how much investment will be needed
to meet these targets here I'm talking
both about the fixed targets for fiber
but also other Target that we have in
them in the in the policy program which
is concerning 5G
here the estimates that we have
currently are 178 billion which is
needed in terms of Investments to reach
these targets by 2050 so we are talking
about significant Investments that are
needed
what we are doing to make this happen on
the commission side in February this
year we proposed a package of measures
very much concentranting on issue of
access to tax and making sure that the
ducts are available
and that the pyramid for example
issuing is very much streamlined so the
two initiatives I'm talking about one is
gigabit infrastructure act which is
focusing on the civic engineering
infrastructure on access to that on
making sure that there is fair access to
that the parameters are streamlined that
the threat tape that is cut to make sure
that the tax can be available for all
that need them but also to make sure
that they are built very quickly the
ducts are absolutely essential also the
cost of tasks is the highest cost of the
of the network we are talking about 70
percent so making sure that this assets
are utilized and used efficiently is
very important so we are now in
negotiations with the Parliament and the
council to make sure that the skip
Capital infrastructure Act is in place
as quickly as possible within the
Mandate of the commission we hope
Mission means that we hope to conclude
negotiations Within one year the second
initiative that we adopted in February
but it's still in under discussion and
we are waiting for opinion from
Regulators from bagak is access
recommendation gigabit recommendation
which is also focusing on several
elements that regulate those need to do
in order to
uh to to to to to prescribe remedies of
access to the networks of the incumbent
I'm talking here about the companies
with Scenic and Market power and here
also the focus of this recommendation is
on access to civil engineering again
access to Dax where we think that the
Regulators in first place when they are
regulating access to networks they
should focus on regulating access to
texts and that in many of the cases
should be sufficient
remedy and they will not necessarily
need to regulate in all cases wholesale
prices of access and the second element
which is also very important in this
recommendation is the fact that we are
trying to incentivize migration from
copper to fiber also through regulatory
instruments and there are only also many
other elements in this recommendation
but focusing on the targets I think
these are the two the most important
okay fantastic so a few things to unpack
and I'd love to come on and talk about
some of the regulatory impact in
different member countries and
particularly thinking about investment
and how things are different but think
about those most recent in recent
initiatives and the infrastructure side
of it particularly so for for operators
having that access to Ducks is something
you think will significantly enhance
their ability to deploy faster yes
absolutely we think that indeed the
access to that should be the primary
remedy that is prescribed by Regulators
of course the situation defects in
member states there are countries like
Spain when the network of tax is very
impressive there are countries which are
not based so much conducts like the
country that I Live Now in Belgium so we
cannot prescribe one remedy for everyone
that's why what we are issuing is a
guidance for The Regulators but it will
be assessment by them of the national
circumstances or even original
circumstances because what we also see
more and more that the situation
competitive situation in different
countries defects not only at the level
of the national level and but it's also
sometimes should be assessed locally
because there are such a big differences
between competition infrastructure
competition in different in different
regions there are new players that are
entering the market many of the
companies that are present here at the
the the very successful companies that
are sometimes taking over the the very
strong position in certain regions of
central countries from the in Tampa so
the the landscape is very much different
now so Regulators need to always take it
into account and not only look at the
markets nationally but sometimes go very
deeply locally we have examples from
Denmark where regulator decided to look
at the regions according to the
electricity utilities networks because
in in Denmark that was the way to
develop competition they were developed
and deploying fiber so it's it's
completely different landscape and the
role of regulators to assess the
situation nationally but also regionally
is extremely important
yes agree and I think um it'd be good to
get your view on on whether you think
the uh new uh new initiatives are going
to be flexible enough to allow that
because I think everybody's behind the
uh the the main aim but of course as you
said it's different within member
countries and the take-ups different and
the rollouts targets different are we
are these things flexible enough to let
each of the individual countries and
even down to Regional level still
deliver but but comply with the
initiatives as well yes I think so in
case of the gigabit infrastructure act
what we are proposing is regulation so
indeed it's directly applicable to the
member states but the measures that are
there are of General nature as I said
it's it's about streamlining of issuing
of the pyramids it's very much allowing
for the access to the to the ducts and
find access to the ducts
coordination of works for example this
measures that are needed everywhere
irrespective of the of the of the
development of the of the ducts ducts
are absolutely necessary everywhere on
the recommendation Capital
recommendation here we give guidance to
the National regulatory authorities and
its decision of The Regulators how they
will use it they are of course Bound by
the provisions of the of our framework
electronic communications code which
also insists on the access to the access
effect remedy to be considered by
Regulators but they have flexibility in
the way they will implement it and they
will have to take into account and
assess the national circumstances the
commission on its side the measures that
Regulators are taking in this field
either to regulate markets and how to
regulate markets are notified to the
commission so we always look into them
in order to to ensure harmonization
affect and make sure that they are
proportionate and they are supporting
competition supporting Investments still
the the main the main decision the
analysis is done of course by regulators
and we are assessing them from the point
of view of of the framework that we are
all trying to implement successfully
okay well thank you for um taking time
to explain that to us I'm sure everybody
is here is pushing towards the same goal
so it's really important those
Frameworks and regulations are in place
so thank you for taking the time to come
and talk to us thank you very much for
talking with me thanks a lot
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]